hey what's going on everybody i'm dave
rubin
this is the reuben report direct message
for today
may 19 2021 click that subscribe button
on youtube mash that notification bell
maybe you'll see the videos we don't
know but it's worth
a shot doesn't take that much effort
it's a tap for you
and a lifetime of entertainment uh all
right we got a whole bunch to get to
and you know earlier in the week i
talked to you guys about the clown pill
to recap very quickly you all know the
blue pill that's just when you accept
you know the mainstream narrative on
everything that's the way most people
are
probably 70 of the people just ignorance
is bliss
then what we like to do is shift people
to the red pill that's when you realize
you know how many lies are out there
life is a little harder after that
you've sort of seen behind the curtain
and you see that the wizard of oz is
just a little old man
not a giant green head then of course
after that what can come
is the black pill which is then where
you're just depressed about everything
because it's like oh man the system's
evil we're against big tech and the
democrats and the media and it's all
this awful thing and you just kind of
check
out and then earlier in the week well
actually this was on
last friday i was in dallas over at the
blaze studios and i did elijah schaefer
show and he's an actual
journalist who goes out into the field
and interviews people he's been in the
middle of the riots he's paid the price
for it the guy's been punched and
attacked and all sorts of stuff
but i was on his show and they were
talking about the clown pill and the
clown pill is sort of what happens after
the black pill
which is that if you don't want to be
depressed about everything
that in essence you just see stories and
you just start laughing and making fun
of them
now i don't think we can always do that
all the time because we do live in
particularly crazy times but you know
the way i try to do this show i try to
do it with a little bit of humor get you
guys laughing a little bit you know try
to do it with a smile on my face
sometimes
try to not make everybody crazy and with
that as the spirit of today's show
the three stories that we're going to be
covering our first the most important
story
of the week by far you know i know
people are saying oh there's a lot of
problems
in the middle east you know there's gas
lines you know hackers
the president has dementia all of that
kind of stuff but we saw this
story on people magazine uh that gwyneth
paltrow you know she has this store in
la goop
i've been there i'll get to it in a few
minutes uh and someone bought a candle
there
and she sells these candles that
apparently smell like her vagina and
this man is claiming
that he lit the candle and it exploded
so we're gonna get to that
i've got the exploding candle and we're
gonna test it out this is
very exciting okay so there's there's
your clown pill then
your red pill moment which is the second
story we're going to be covering
which is that the democrats have just
become racist period
that's it this is not up for debate
anymore you have basically
racist democrats and silent pathetic
anemic
impotent democrats that's really all
that there is left
uh raphael warnock who's the uh senator
one of the new senators from atlanta uh
he was giving a commencement speech
and you'll hear some of his racist stuff
and then lori lightfoot who we talked
about the other day the woman who looks
like beetlejuice who's the mayor of uh
chicago she's only granting interviews
to black or brown journalists yes really
these people are racist that's it
and then finally and i guess this is
sort of the this isn't red pill
well i guess this is a a red pill i want
a new one
is it what's the white pill exactly i
want to know what the white pill is
because
this is a great story actually so you
may remember the mccloskeys this was the
family
in missouri that during the height of
the black lives matter
riots and just wandering through
residential neighborhoods and burning
things down and destroying stores and
everything else
you may remember this couple that
actually went out there
and had the the wife had a little a
little pistol
the the man had a shotgun uh and then of
course the media tried to turn on them
called them white supremacists and
everything else there's no reason to
think
that these people were anything other
than upstanding citizens he was
was and is a lawyer well the media tried
to destroy him and this guy has now
decided to run for senate
in missouri so yes that is the white
pill story
so we're doing a clown pill story about
gwen paltrow's exploding vagina
we're doing a red pill story which is
the democrats are racist we've got to
see it and we've got to talk about it
and then the white pill is the
optimistic pill and the mccloskeys
uh give us reason for hope because good
people are getting
in the game so i'm excited to do the
show today
and the coffee tastes good all right
guys so gwyneth paltrow has this store
here in los angeles i've been to the
store it's in i think it's in the
brentwood market or something very elite
market it's a super expensive store you
know it's a lot of celebrity nonsense
they're overpriced water and
all that crap well uh we've got a quote
from
people.com a texas man is suing gwyneth
paltrow's wellness
brand goop after he says his scented
candle exploded
colby watson filed a class-action
lawsuit in california on monday
alleging that he purchased the famous
this smells like my vagina candle
for 75 from the goop website in january
according to court documents obtained
by nbc news in the complaint watson says
that upon
lighting the candle for the first time
it exploded
and was engulfed in high flames after it
had been
burning for about three hours the news
outlet reports
no injuries were reported so i want to
be very clear about something i have
been to goop i mean it's just sort of
elite high priced overpriced nonsense
her vagina smelling candle costs 75
we mostly get our candles at ikea in
this house
not to say if you've got the cash and
you want to spend it on the expensive
candles we do enjoy
some nice candles too i like a
sandalwood anyway we've been to goop and
a few months ago it was i mean i don't
know maybe it was before the lockdowns i
guess it was before the lockdowns
haven't been anywhere
ever time has just melted
uh we went into goop because we heard
about the uh the vagina
smelling candle and you know i've been
out of that game for a while but i
thought all right let me let me see
what's going on over here
and i smelled the vagina candle and
didn't smell like much didn't smell like
much i don't know if that's more of a
a commentary on gwyneth paltrow's actual
vagina or if that's a commentary
on just whatever they're putting in the
candle that's
you know for other people to decide but
anyway we did buy
the uh exploding vagina candle so i've
got it here and you know one of the
things i talk about on the show all the
time
on this very special clown episode of
the reuben report
is that nobody does journalists
journalism anymore right nobody really
does journalism anymore these people
just comment on things they
they're not journalists in a traditional
sense of being out there on the field
figuring out what is what they just tell
you what they think about everything
as i always say i'm not a journalist i'm
telling you what i think but i'm being
honest about it
anywho i thought i'd do a little
journalism here right now we've got
the gwyneth paltrow this smells like my
vagina candle
and i'm going to light it right now and
we'll see what happens
big show big show today guys okay so
here we go i mean i can't imagine
anything
is going to happen with equinox paltrow
is an upstanding member of our hollywood
society this is a good woman you know
what i mean why would
she have an exploding vagina candle it's
just crazy but anyway
i'm gonna go ahead here we go
i did not expect that i guess it's an
exploding
vagina candle oh my god can you believe
it
all right guys there it is there is the
clown pill
story of today are you guys proud of the
work that we're doing around here
michael's giving me the look like
i better update my resume
anyway i just thought that was so stupid
and ridiculous and i was also looking
for an excuse to
you know show the exploding death star
as always
um but like i just felt like everyone
needed a little break from the nonsense
so i hope you enjoyed that story i hope
none of you have the candle
and uh and you know what actually any of
you that do
have the vagina the gwyneth paltrow
vagina smelling candle
i don't care if it explodes or i'd
actually like to just know if you think
it truly smells like her vagina and like
i would also love to know
like the process by which they were able
to figure that out you know what it
means did they have scientists down
there was
was fouchy down there you know what i
mean trust the science so fauci's down
you know they've got
gwyneth paltrow like this and fouchy's
down there oh we're in the bottom of the
six
i guess i have to stay here for a little
bit longer
all right let's talk about the democrats
they're they're all just
absolutely terrible and we're going to
show you this clip of raphael warnock in
a second giving this commencement speech
and of course talking about 1619 which
in essence i know you guys
most of you know this already the 16-19
project was this ridic
ridiculous factually flawed project that
the new york times put out there that
they subsequently admitted was not
factual
and even some of the people who put the
whole project together
admitted that it was more narrative than
based on fact but the the basic idea of
the 1619 project
is that in 1619 that's the real founding
of america it's not 1776
but 1619 because america is
fundamentally
founded on slavery and racism this is
just simply not true you know my
feelings on what a wonderful country
america is although we're running pretty
thin at the moment
um and we may need a sort of second
revolution or at least that
that kind of spirit i don't mean that in
sort of a violent terms but just like
a renewal of the american spirit it
feels like we we desperately need that
but the democrats have become radical
there are there are virtually no
non-radical leftist democrats there are
no
good liberals left if you are a liberal
and you are watching this
you are a modern conservative i know
it's scary it took a long time
for me to realize it too but the
conservatives have a wide freaking tent
of plurality of opinion of people who
want to live and restore and rejuvenate
this great nation so this is raphael
warnock who just
became senator of georgia you may
remember that they won both
those seats and and i just want to add
one more thing before we get to the clip
which is that right after
the election i had a a big party at my
house it was
an illegal party but you know i'm a
radical freedom extremist and i had
about 50 people here and it was a lot of
people that you sort of know through the
show and sort of well-known political
people and tv people and all that
and i had a whole bunch of people who
were sort of anti-trump people
that uh some of them actually privately
voted for trump but that were anti-trump
people but they all kept saying because
the uh
the atlanta elections were in january
they were like oh you know what we'll
keep the senate
meaning the republicans will win the
senate and that that sort of division in
government will stop the true
radicalism from coming and i kept saying
to people well a i don't know that the
republicans are going to win
and in fact the republicans lost both
seats but also if you think
that what can save the system is like
one senator like
there's so many people that think that
joe manchin because he's not a
completely psychotic
leftist that he can save the union and
it's like that stuff's not working
anyway this is a very short clip listen
to raphael
warnock democratic senator from
georgia giving a commen commencement
speech
go forth don't just teach us how to make
our way out of covet 19
teach us how to make our way out of
covet 16
19. so you see what he's doing
now first off virtually nobody clapped
okay that's fine
um but what they're trying to do is so
first off we've got the kovid 19 thing
now we all realize
it's wrapping up whatever kovit needed
to do for the system
it did if it was to break people if it
was to destroy lives if it was to
empower
awful politicians whatever it needed to
do if it was here solely to get rid of
trump
whatever the entire machine needed kovid
to be
it did it and we're sort of moving past
it now so he's saying okay well you guys
got to lead us out of cover 19 but also
out of covid 16 19 what he is saying
there this is a senator
in the united states senate a democratic
senator
saying you must lead us out of this
meaning america was founded on racism
and bigotry
and slavery now i believe that he
believes that and
that is the problem that is the problem
i don't think that the average well
it's hard to say at this point i don't
know what the average democrat voter is
right now
right are they all radical extremists
and for a long time it was just this
yipping dog
that that barked much louder than its
bite well now it's like well what really
is this thing because if the party has
nobody left to stand up like where is
somebody in the party where are the
leaders of the party
say nancy pelosi hopped up on her
expensive ice cream or
you know chuck schumer who's utterly
useless where are they to say
uh uh raphael you know you're the new
guy in the senate and we appreciate you
and uh you know we're happy you won and
you beat those scary
trump republican types but no
america is not evil and racist and when
you tell that as a commencement speaker
when you tell that to a group of young
people who are going to be the people
that lead us into the future
you're actually burning down america now
of course we know
that pelosi and schumer and the rest of
whatever
an old school democrat is most of the
good ones are dead
shout out to jfk
we just know they're not going to do
anything they have no power and this is
the future of the party uh for a little
context
and i discussed this a bit actually in
my interview with nigel farage
last week what is happening to our
democratic party right now is what
already
has happened to the labour party which
in effect is the left
party in the uk they went full on
radical extremists left they bought
identity politics they bought hatred of
the nation and all of that stuff now
fortunately
in the following election after they
went that deep and jeremy corbyn who's
like a true
anti-semite and i don't you know you
guys know i don't use those terms
lightly right i don't run around calling
people
bigots or anything else like that unless
it's actually warranted
um i think and and here's the here's the
white pill version of this
we got a midterm election coming up in a
year and it's like these people
all gotta go now i understand that
raphael warnock is you know he's in for
six years
but i mean when whatever congressional
seats can be won back by republicans get
every democrat out i hate to sound so
partisan in that regard right like i'm
not even a member
of the republican party i don't even
mean this as a it's democrat versus
conservative lib brothers
democrat vs republican liberal versus
conservative or any of that stuff it's
bait you
do you like america do you think any of
this is good do you think your
grandparents or great grandparents
came to something that was better than
the thing that they left and would you
prefer
that the thing that they left that awful
you in most cases communism or socialism
or something even worse nazism whatever
it is do you think that that should be
imported here and if you think that
should be important here then you should
vote for the democrats
but i don't think that's what most
people want and and
man again we got to get braver quicker
we really got to get braver quicker
but if you don't think a sitting senator
announcing to a group of young college
students that they're going to have to
fight
against in essence this racist nation if
you don't think that's scary enough or
or ridiculous enough
uh we've got a quote here from a
journalist at nbc5 in chicago her name
is mary
ann ahern and this is about laurie
lightfoot she says quote
the mayor's communication director told
me only
black or brown journalists would get a
one-on-one
i expressed my outrage but nothing has
changed
so lori lightfoot is a racist lori
lightfoot is also deeply
anti-science we played a video i believe
it was yesterday that she is going to
continue to wear masks even though she's
vaccinated she just loves controlling
people also in her city of chicago
41 people were shot this past weekend
now we know nobody cares about that
because it's 99
every weekend it's black people shooting
other black people and if you talk about
that they'll tell you a rate you're
you know they'll tell you you're a
racist and all of those things but this
is a this is a
serious escalation like i get it the
left is completely bananas
these are not good people they have been
rotted and
corroded and they don't know what they
believe and all of that stuff
all of that stuff right i get it but
this is a massive escalation this is
a sitting mayor not just saying what
warnock said which is ah america's
racist we gotta we gotta flip that or
any of the nonsense
that aoc is saying or that ilhan omar or
rashida talib is saying like they're all
deeply anti-american i mean do you think
any of them honestly care about the
constitution
which is what they swore to protect when
they signed their oath of office and i
think if there's a smart lawyer out
there people should start looking into
at what point have they clearly violated
their oath of office but but i get
you know i get it the ship is sort of
sailed on like a functional
defense i suppose or something like that
um
but this is deeply dangerous because
this is now okay
i am a mayor she happens to be black i
don't care that she's black i wouldn't
care if she's white either she's just a
bad mayor
an awful mayor who as i said yesterday
when biden got elected she was out there
with the crowds without a mask saying oh
well we can take the mask off because we
got to be happy
now she's got an extra mask even though
the cdc doesn't even want her to wear
masks anymore and people are getting
killed in her city and and the economics
there are a disaster and everything else
but now she's saying i'll only be
interviewed by black people
the anti-racists that right the
self-proclaimed anti-racists
are the racist please show me
anyone on the right a conservative show
me
anyone in the trump world show me any
any
sane person please find one for me
please so i can have a maya culpa and
retract this tomorrow
show me anyone outside of progressive
circles that will only be
interviewed by people of their race but
that's what the anti-racists want do you
guys get it yet
these are the racists they are here to
destroy the legacy of martin luther king
jr as a matter of fact we played it also
yesterday
joe biden said that george floyd's death
will have more worldwide impact
than martin luther king jr and as i you
know i gave credit where it's due he may
be right in the most sick perverse
twisted way which is that the everything
that has happened in the last couple
years
is a complete erasure of martin luther
king jr so martin luther king's
junior's legacy of freedom and and
respect for the individual
and equality for all people and that
hope that his children wouldn't be
judged by the color of their skin but by
the content of their character
well all of that is being erased and now
there is a world wide
movement to re-segregate us to
re-racialize everything
and in many ways america is the
epicenter of all of it
because we've done it better than
everyone
everyone in the history of the world we
have brought more people here for more
success and more freedom and more
everything else and that's why nobody
leaves so even this morning i saw some
idiotic tweet about bernie sanders
babbling on about
the price that people uh pay you know
mcdonald's in denmark pays their
employees 22.
and it's like yeah mcdonald's denmark
also has 35
tax rates for almost everybody the
burgers do cost
more denmark's also a tiny nordic
country it's like just go
go to denmark you old socialist buffoon
nobody wants you here like just leave
please it would
like leave if it's so terrible it's so
terrible like maybe
i should start a gofundme to get rid of
some of these people what if we just
start a gofundme and it's like you guys
hate
this place so much like i don't want to
jail you
i know you'd prefer to jail your
political opponents i i don't want to
hurt you in any way
but i'd like to help you actually i'd
like to help bernie i'd like to help aoc
and ohan omar and rashida talib
and all of these people that hate this
place so much i'd love i'd like to help
lori lightfoot and and uh warnock
it's like let's put together a big
gofundme and it's like you guys want to
go to denmark
denmark's gonna have to build a wall uh
anyway i think i've made my
feelings clear on this we gotta we got a
big problem guys we got a big
problem because we have a racist party
in the united states and the media is
trying to trick you
into thinking that everyone else is
racist and it just
ain't true that's your red pill story
and now let's do your white pill story
because i actually think this is
freaking phenomenal
you may remember mark mccloskey and his
wife
from a couple of months back at the
height of the black lives matter riots
which by the way have cost about two
billion dollars
worth of damage we're not really allowed
to talk about that though and the
general lawlessness that took
you know took place across america
throughout the summer and into the fall
and you know it's
happening now by the way we didn't even
play the video but just yesterday
last night in los angeles i tweeted it
out if you'd if you want to see it i
didn't even wanna it's one of those
things where it's like i don't want to
add
fuel to the fire but there was a group
of jewish people sitting outside in west
hollywood
which is right by beverly hills right by
the la cienega area it's a big jewish
community there
and a bunch of palestinian activists
just jump out of a car and attack them
that's happening on the streets
of los angeles the city that i'm in
right now
and you won't see that on cnn new york
times ain't going to cover that right if
there was a fake
actor who was black and gay who hired
his
two cousins or whatever it was to put a
rope around his neck and say he attacked
him
while he was walking out of subway then
you know nancy pelosi and aoc would be
telling us this is proof of systemic
racism but random jews
you know eating outside at a sushi place
just getting mauled by a group of
palestinian protesters let's not let's
not talk about that anyway i link this
to mark mccloskey because you may
remember last summer this is the guy
who they busted into his street which
was a private gated street
in the middle of burning all this stuff
down and he and his wife actually
defended
their property but if you don't remember
let's take a look
[Music]
yes
[Music]
all right so to be absolutely clear he
lived on a private
street they broke through the gate at
the private street he did not shoot
anybody
you know i remember a lot of people were
upset about the way that his wife was
holding the gun
okay fine he was called a white
supremacist his wife was called a white
supremacist
they were docs they were attacked people
tried to take out his law firm all of
the usual stuff all that man did
was in a time when cities were burning
would say
this is mine i am the king of this
castle i deserve a place on this earth
that i own
and i can protect which is the god-given
right given to all of us in the united
states at least for now they'd love to
come take it
um well after all of that surviving all
the machine and the cancel culture and
just all the stuff
well he's actually putting his money
where his mouth is he's somebody that
almost got destroyed
but is now fighting back and he is
running for senator
in missouri here's his campaign at
when the angry mob came to destroy my
house and kill
my family i took a stand against them
now i'm asking for the privilege to take
that stand
for all of us i will never
back down our nation is under attack
big tech big business the swamp in dc
are all working together to destroy our
god-given freedom
our culture and our heritage when was
the last time
a politician defended you defended
america
stood between you and the mob we need
defenders but all we get is dividers
every day they teach us to hate each
other
left versus right black versus white
rich versus poor
this is a tactic to destroy us but we
are all americans
we are missourians our nation our state
our homes are worth defending our
freedoms
are worth defending i can promise you
one thing
that when the mob comes to destroy our
homes our state
and our country i will defend them i
will never
back down that is a good man right there
that is not someone that wanted to be a
politician that is not someone
i sense that wanted to be in the fight
at this public level he was obviously
a successful lawyer before this but that
is someone who the world
struck at him and he decided to strike
back that's more of the spirit that we
need
i don't know all of his policy positions
i don't care about all of his policy
positions i suspect we probably have
some political differences however i
have no doubt
that if i lived in missouri i would vote
for
that man now what will be interesting is
the mob will strike
back right like there will be many many
more hit pieces on him
wait till all the national democrats and
their allies
at cnn and everywhere else decide to
figure out all the hit pieces they can
put out there
and then funnel all the money in right
they're going to just funnel a ton
of money to destroy this guy which in
many ways is the most anti-american
thing you can do because states have a
right to decide who their elected
representatives are
but this is the new thing which is like
what happened actually in georgia when
when warnock
was uh elected there was a ton
of outside money being poured into
georgia so the democrats could get what
they want and democrats generally are
better with this sort of thing you may
remember andrew yang and
sort of over andrew yang he turned out
to be the sort of worst sort of just
nothingness
democrat everybody thought he was sort
of the moderate well he's just sort of
nothing
but he was campaigning in georgia to get
this guy elected
it's like what do you have to do with
that andrew yang like
this is why politics is so whacking
we've got to get back
to local politics states rights and
and all of those things anyway so mark
mccloskey if you're watching this or if
anyone on your team is watching this
i would love to interview you it would
be an absolute pleasure no need for
notes let's just talk about all of it
see what happens
we will reach out obviously through the
proper channels oh and that does remind
me of one other thing that i want to say
before
we end the show today which is that you
know as you guys know i've sort of in
these last two three weeks sort of
supported
i say supported i've i've said nice
things and
somewhat promoted uh caitlyn jenner who
is running
against gavin newsom in this california
recall election we have repeatedly
repeatedly on this show reached out
through all the proper channels
to her team we haven't heard back i've
tweeted at her many times
my tweets get way more traffic than any
of her tweets do
so i know that either she or the intern
who's running the twitter account
or the team are seeing it so it is my
belief at this point
that this will sort of be my last effort
at this that if we don't at least hear
back the fact that nobody is responding
to us
you don't have to do the show you can
just politely you know say no we're not
doing it
or we're figuring out the media stuff or
whatever it is my belief at this point
that the
the caitlyn jenner thing is a complete
sham i i just don't think it's real i
think they put together a nice
slick ad and i'm guessing she has a
reality show team with her i don't know
that for a fact
but i would love to know if that's true
because i'm guessing it is but i don't
believe it's a real
campaign which is a damn shame because
california needed somebody
to stand up and in an odd way maybe it
was supposed to be someone like kailyn
jenner to kind of flip this whole thing
on its head
i don't mean to make this about me
specifically but the point is i've been
one of the most outspoken people
in in california i have a pretty big
platform here to get the voice out and
if your team is so inept
that they just don't respond we've tried
on on every proper front
behind the scenes and i've done it
publicly the fact that you guys don't
even respond
either this is an unserious campaign and
you're just using it
for pr purposes for a new reality show
or something like that or you're
completely mismanaged
so i say that with no animosity i say
that with no hatred or malice or
anything else
i guess we'll give it another day or two
for someone to just respond
you don't have to do the show obviously
caitlyn if you think i'm you know too
much of a hard interview because that's
what i'm really known as
you know i really beat my so my
interview subjects into
into pulp um but otherwise at this point
after weeks we also donated 50 bucks
i've got the stupid mug
um you know it's just a pr campaign that
that's all i think it is which is a damn
shame because gavin newsom should not be
the governor
of this state anymore and unfortunately
i don't see anyone else i'll support
literally anyone else
but i don't see anyone else out there so
i would love to know what's really going
on there caitlyn and i think it's
probably
just a pr stunt and and absolutely
nothing more than that
anywho guys uh part three of my
interview if you want a little red pill
and a little clown pill and a little
white pill part three
of my interview with michael malus who
you guys know how i feel about him the
willy wonka of politics he dressed
like q from the dc comics uh
it is up on youtube right now there's
three parts part three just went up this
morning the full episode is up already
ad free reubenreport.locals.com
and uh all right get out there watch out
with your candles people i mean this
could have killed me this could have
been it could have just blown up
and that would have been it lordy lordy
all right have a great day everybody
more tomorrow